alors bonsoir Barbara Romagnan vous
étiez donc candidate députée sortante
pour la première circonscription du dou
celle de de besonçon on a entendu
beaucoup de de députés d'anciens députés
avoir un sentiment de de gâie des
députés donc qui n'ont pas été réélus
comme comme vous ce soir comment vous
vous vous le vivez j'ais dire d'un point
de vue personnel est-ce qu'il y a ce
sentiment d'avoir été balayé emporté
justement par la vague la République en
marche oui mais c'est la démocratie les
citoyens avaient un choix à faire ils
sont libres de faire les choix qui qui
il veulent alors je ne suis pas député
que de besonçon parce que si ça avait
été le cas je l'aurais emporté il ne
vous a pas échappé que malgré le soutien
du Premier ministre et du maire de la
ville je suis en tête sur besonçon
malgré le soutien pour votre adversaire
je le précise oui pardon je vous
remercie malgré le soutien pour mon
adversaire et puis je voulais parce que
là il y a que les élus ou battus qui
viennent parler mais il y a aussi
beaucoup de gens avec nous qui font
campagne qu'on qu'on ne voit pas qui
s'investissent gratuitement pendant des
mois et des mois donc VO voilà c'est
aussi pour eux que c'est que c'est une
déception et c'est aussi surtout eux que
je voulais remercier est-ce que vous
savez ce que vous allez faire c'était
votre seul mandat qu'est-ce que vous
faites demain lundi bah demain peut-être
que je prendrai un petit peu de temps
mais ben je vais retourner travailler
euh vous êtes enseignante je ne suis pas
fonctionnaire donc je n'ai pas de poste
qui m'attend donc je vais retourner
chercher du travail sans doute pas dès
demain et puis je vais me préoccuper
aussi de ceux qui travaillaient avec moi
euh qui eux du coup aussi perdent
perdent leur travail mais voilà surtout
je vais retourner dans la vie plus
normale comme on dit et et ce que vivent
aussi beaucoup beaucoup de nos
concitoyens et voilà c'est une bonne
chose aussi pour ça euh et votre
engagement politique ah ben moi je suis
une militant de politique donc ça ne
change rien à mon engagement politique
mon engagement n'est pas lié à mon
mandat j'étais heureuse de pouvoir
porter ce que j'ai apporté et le faire
aussi au nom d'autres dans le cadre de
ce mandat là et je suis triste de devoir
arrêter mais je suis militante politique
et c'est peu dire dire que il y a encore
des objets de d'investissement moi je
voulais elle est pas là mais je voulais
féliciter madame charvier de sa victoire
mais aussi vraiment attirer son
attention moi je doute pas de évidemment
de sa bonne volonté et de son souci de
représenter les citoyens mais vraiment
je l'alerte et je demande d'être très
très vigilante sur la question de cette
loi travail il faut pas voter les
ordonnances aués au au Premier ministre
il y a beaucoup de gens à Besançon
autour mais ailleurs qui qui ne vivent
que de leur travail qui n'ont que ça
beaucoup de gens qui sont obligés de
passer d'un contrat à un autre vous
savez avec qu' aujourd'hui 80 % des CDD
sont inférieurs à un mois donc on peut
pas voter une loi comme ça c'est ça
c'est pas une loi qui crée de l'emploi
c'est juste une loi qui fragilise les
salariés et l'autre alerte que j'ai
vraiment très très forte c'est sur la
situation à Calais dans le reste de la
France aussi sur la façon dont on en
France on traite des gens qui quittent
des pays en guerre qui veulent sauver
leur vie et quand ils sont en France là
à Calais on les empêche de boire on les
empêche de manger et on pénalise les
militants qui essayent simplement de
venir au secours de de gens qui sont
dans une immense détresse